ladies and gentlemen I am actually
thrilled to be able to say this uh the
legendary voice of Optimus Prime Peter
Cullen
are you all settled in yes I am yes
roll out okay
uh I really want to say sincere I really
mean this I've been a fan of yours since
I was a kid uh it is a real thrill to
have you here and I think for all of us
you grew up with Transformers uh and I
don't do this too often but I really
want to give you a thank you
[Applause]
sincerely thank you for your work you
guys look really comfortable I mean well
no wonder look she Whiz I was sitting in
a theater in New York City yesterday and
they were so old
I mean they still had bubble gum under
the seats yeah
this is
the IMAX headquarters and before we go
any further I said it before but I'll
say it again a huge thank you to IMAX
for being such an awesome sponsor and to
Paramount for letting us screen the
movie
um so
I have a bunch of questions I want to
start with going back in time uh when
did you first get involved in doing uh
voices for TV
or how did you get first involved
um what with television well I I you
have to go back further
when I was a kid I could do sounds
and then eventually I could do my
teachers
and and
um I used to get in a lot of trouble I
mean I really did I flunked first grade
I did yeah I did and because I was I
just could make people laugh man when I
worked on the farm my aunts had a farm
up in Upstate New York and I could do
all the animals by the end of the the
summer I had I could do horses like cows
and dogs cats slam sheep pigs chickens
anything I could do at the end of the
year
and then of course grade two was a
disaster because you know I would
interrupt every class with it
[Music]
wait a minute wait I was a calf nah
but anyway nonetheless uh that was the
beginning
and eventually
uh it came to
um High School
and then I got into elocution and
elocution led to
the end of high school and the then the
National Theater School of Canada
where I would impersonate everybody
so I would just impersonate people
and that led to getting parts
and then it led to Comedy and so I got
into comedy in Canada with a show called
funny you should say that
and comedy Cafe on television Johnny
Jelly Bean and his friends
all these wonderful vehicles to be funny
which brought me to California
to do a show called it's a wacky world
that was going to replace Laugh-In
it's a two-hour special at
just dialed off
but at the same time they needed an
announcer
to do a sound of a little Gremlin inside
a ball
and then it would say it's the Sonny and
sure show so I ended up
being the announcer on the sunny and
share show as well as the little guy in
the ball
and I don't know
flags and all that stuff going on ladies
and gentlemen sunny and Cher and him so
that led on to television
it was yeah that was the that was how it
happened
from a little kid in the first grade all
the way to the little guy in the ball
I'm so curious you've done obviously
tons of voices as you've already
demonstrated besides Optimus uh when you
go in when you went in for some parts uh
whether whatever it may be how much was
it you the night before like coming up
with the voice and how much is was it a
collaboration with the director of the
project or you know what I mean what was
that relationship like to find the voice
of a character actually would just be my
interpretation of what was written down
uh you would see a a sketch of the
character what it looked like and then
an example of it some of its dialogue
and I would always create it according
to how it was built if it had a neck I'd
make it more trumpet or you know more
strangled it was larger more air deeper
and then I looked at its comedy traits
and how funny is it going to be and uh
how is he funny is he funny verbally or
is he funny the way he says it or I'll
be of some obstruction you know maybe
his lips are twisted or something yeah
whatever so that's how most of them came
to be would be the immediate
interpretations on seeing the picture
you have done countless voices besides
Optimus and we're going to get to
Optimus but what are some of your
favorite characters that are not name
Optimus Prime uh I love the the
characters that were easiest to do
um you know
that didn't require a lot of screaming
and yelling and stuff like that because
screaming and yelling is hard work but
my favorite was uh outside of prime was
Eeyore
Flying Spur Motors and me
not that anybody cares many
if you don't mind me asking when when
you're recording say Eeyore or Optimus
do you have a an amount of time before
your voice gets tired or can you do it
for like hours and you've done the vocal
uh you know training that it can go all
day well yeah that's a good question I I
did uh King Kong and I played not only
King Kong I had to play uh Mrs Kong and
uh baby Kong too so at the end of 11
years uh 11 reels I lost my voice and I
was coughing up blood
so I said I wouldn't I'm not gonna told
my agent I said I'm not going to do any
more these
monster stuff it's just too hard and
then uh
20th Century Fox called the agency and
said we'd like to have Peter to um help
us with this voice for the predator
yeah so that's how we give it
who are you
[Laughter]
I've literally my next question was uh
was literally about predator and so do a
lot of people know that you did
Predators one of these things where fans
come up to you and want to talk about it
or is it always Optimus well I'm I have
a way of squeezing all that stuff in
somehow I
somebody because my imagination just
keeps rolling around and uh that last
question you made about you know is it
is it difficult to do that stuff and I
said yeah that's how I came up with the
Predator because it wasn't a strain on
The Voice
and how I came up with that
um I've told this story many times I'm
sure some of you know it
but uh years ago on the beach in
Massachusetts on the uh
at low tide there was an upside down
horseshoe crab and it was a hot day and
the bubbles were coming out of it and
it's like legs are like this you know
and all those bubbles are breaking and
they're making that little
so
uh I figured that's stuck in my brain
and when they asked me to do the
predator
what do you see this gray streak went
across the screen and they say come up
can you come up with something and I
said
yeah
bring that studio mic down here it was
one that was a way up there about 20
feet
and I said no bring it down and I the
director behind me is getting really
annoyed and so they finally get it down
to about right here where I need it and
I I just said
I could I did it better back in those
days as this streak went across the
screen
and he got so so annoyed he's all right
that's enough okay okay all right he got
up and the voice came from behind him he
said you better come up here and listen
to this
[Laughter]
he went up and he was so cranky going up
those stairs
in about five minutes later he comes
he's going like this he just found his
happiness streaked and there it was and
so we did the whole the whole film in
that day in that day yeah to get into
all of it every every reel
and they've been using it ever since
I was going to say that that is they are
free
I was going to say that's a night that's
an iconic sound that everybody knows and
it was just just luck and you know what
came out of me at the time yeah for me
uh I know you've talked about it before
but we're filming this and I'm sure
there's going to be people in here who
don't know but let's let's jump into the
Optimus voice and talk about uh when you
first auditioned talk a little bit about
going in for the role and did you have
what was it like did you know what it
was when you were auditioning how did
you come up with that voice when you
were first going in yeah
the first time I I told this story and I
almost cried
uh the um
my brother and I well first of all my
brother was a captain in the Marine
Corps bought in Vietnam and he was
decorated bronze star with v and purple
hearts Etc
and when he came home years later uh we
were
sharing an apartment together
and we had one car I was going through
it
difficult time of my life and uh
so we were stuck with the one car and
constantly
he was bigger by five inches you know 13
months older
and a marine and if he wanted that car
he got the car
period
Peter do you need the car I said I
yellar he said
how long he said oh
maybe an hour an hour and a half maybe
see what are you gonna do he said all
right I'm going to an audition
oh not another one Peter you get to get
a job one of these days so I said no no
it'll happen it'll happen
he said what are you auditioning for I
said a truck
a truck
what does a truck sound like I said
Larry I don't I don't know it's a hero
he's a hero truck he's a truck so he's
he's gonna be a hero it's a new new
cartoon series for kids and he said his
face got very serious and he just
Peter
if you're gonna be here it'll be a real
hero
don't be one of those Hollywood
Pretenders
don't go yelling and screaming and
pretending you're a tough guy
be strong enough to be gentle
and that hung in my brain I'm driving
to the audition when I get there and I
look at them
page and it says I am Optimus Prime
leader of the Cyber Trump
and I just
Peter Cullen take one and I said okay I
said I could have said my name is Larry
Cullen
get out of God
and I rang out as K company Third
Battalion fifth Marines first and I said
wow but I just did it
in his voice just saying my name is
Optimus Prime
from the planet Cybertron
leader of the Autobots and that's
banging that I read the rest of it and
said Thank you and they said thank you
got in the station wagon and drove home
he said I said Larry
it really went well and I thank you he
said what for
he said I just impersonated you
foreign
three weeks later I found out I got the
job
[Applause]
what do you think it is about Optimus
that has caused like generations of kids
and adults to just love this character
well you know
I would have loved that character
if I were a kid
because I I you know I feel my brother
Larry all the time and he was one of the
greatest human beings I've ever known a
funny kind
sensitive
strong
uh courageous
I mean he did everything you know he
played professional football he taught
University he built houses there was
nothing he didn't do and uh
you know as a giver of advice and
his friends were
so many so many he had one of the most
incredible
funerals at uh
in DC you know it was with the flyover I
mean uh
it made me cry and it was synonymous
with who he was and that's who Prime is
and that's why I love doing Prime and
because it's not me it's my brother
and when when he has to say things that
I don't think Larry would say
I'll tell him
I'll say you know he wouldn't say that
he wouldn't say that and he said what
are you saying I said no no I don't
think Prime would say that
you've voiced the character I believe
for for 40 years when when you're in the
booth how much ownership do you have do
you feel as Larry or as optimists when
you're saying those lines when you know
is it something you know what I mean
with are you ever changing that word or
how much ownership do you have oh I
don't stumble for a second
um
no Prime is inside of me
you know because it's just the
associative
blessing that I have with them
with my kin you know with Larry it's
just there's no
I said this there's no variation on it
at all it's it's that or nothing you
know I'm so curious because you were
voicing Optimus in the 80s and you're
voicing Optimus now what was it like
recording in the 80s versus versus
recording Optimus now oh
uh well start it you don't forget I did
Optimus Prime
up until the movie in 1986 and uh
where I was put to rest
I literally so Optimus Prime
you see a kid adding me and I didn't
come back I wasn't resurrected until the
first Michael Bay film so there's a lot
of time in between
and however I did come back for to do a
couple of two or three shows
because the the kids a lot of kids
evidently had trouble with that that
scene and they were not coming out of
the rooms and hiding under beds I was
told
so they brought me back for three shows
the mothers of America
went to the powers to be and so they had
to bring me back but then I was
that's when I went to sleep again
permanently
and I um didn't touch it until that that
first movie with Michael what was it
like though back in the is the recording
similar is it different what was it like
back then versus the way it is now
foreign
it was fun it was a lot of fun we would
be how many actors on that show we we
had so many and we'd all line up
standing behind our microphones
and in that uh
in that room were some of the most
talented greatest guys you know and
girls couple and behind the glass
windows you know the directors and other
people
and they would have to tolerate us and
we were we were always doing and you
could stay people smoked in those days
so I mean that place was just a madhouse
you know
all right you have to smoke I don't
smoke well who's smoking here
oh it's me I'm sorry see
but Frank Welker you know he and I we
got along so well together and we ended
up doing a lot of series together
and uh we had fun I mean
I mean real fun you would be in a very
serious situation and all of a sudden
you'd hear what would sound like an
elevator in the background you know and
age episode
what's the sound he says oh there's an
elevator back there he said
that's not an elevator and in fact we do
his elevator
or he'd do a leaky faucet or he'd do a
bird outside a window I mean he could
just do it he's the king anyway so we
had a lot of laughter and a lot of
laughter and that was
that was great and then what came along
in the movie I worked alone
I worked alone that was
Michael Bay and I in a in a sound booth
go sound room and um
with a camera on my lips
one about where the third row is and one
right here on the side staring right at
me
you know bring your face
and you had to get over that and so
and when working just to pencil sketches
in some cases you know Optimus Prime
furry do something with all this stuff
going on and it's just a pencil sketch
and doing my lines and then
Michael would say something to the
effect Peter
um can you can you make him
bigger
make them bigger he's 45 feet tall you
know
I said yeah and you know on television
he's only about this thing
[Laughter]
is that okay so that changed the voice a
little bit you know and I used to have a
lot of fun back in the early days you
know I didn't even throw on a little
John Wayne you know what do you say
mister
just for the fun of it
a couple of ducks
I'm take your pillow Peter which one
whoops I'm sorry so uh you spoke on the
animated movie uh I saw that when I was
much younger and I love that line uh one
shall stand one shall fall and the way
you deliver that line it has some
awesome animation in that movie when you
were doing that scene that line did you
realize that like it's a big moment I
think for a lot of Transformers fans did
you realize uh it was going to be a big
moment yeah yeah for sure yeah that's a
that's a good old
grunt guy get it online you know one
shall stand one shall fall you know
you know
do you uh can you if you don't mind can
let's go back a little bit when you were
recording that because that the animated
movie did you what was it like recording
the animated movie because that was a
really big deal at the time after the
animated series and it was going to be
in theaters you know what did it mean to
you what was it like recording it
ah
the the first movie yeah the animated
movie from the 80s yeah
well I I gotta be honest you know I was
sitting next to Frank
Frank Welker and uh I got to the point
where I said hey Frank where are you
she's on page three he says I'm on 17.
I'm getting whacked
what he said I'm I'm
and I don't come back
no way and I said yeah yeah no way
gee we're so wow
I didn't really care after that I didn't
care that's it on to another show on to
another job I don't know what it's going
to be doesn't care it doesn't matter
that's what show business is especially
in voiceover because you do more than uh
three voices you get paid for one and
you have to do three
and if you do four you have to get paid
an extra
care so we always wanted to do four of
course Frank welcome he did he'd do
eight voices
and he had this huge house I don't know
anyway
so it's it's how many uh series you did
you know we did I did back in those days
we did a ton of series it's not like
today
yeah it's not like today back in those
days you you had to do multiple voices
but a lot of the kids today they they
only can do one voice a lot of them and
some of them do it at home
she
and they get paid a fortune
well he's we just can't I think we got
paid 123 dollars a show
back in the day yeah
and we do three we'd have to do three
characters
yeah
and then they the reruns
they rerun up until 10 they would the
prices would come down down downtown so
you had to do volume in those days you
had to do a lot you know to break it you
know to get into it to get there
you know and and get a couple of hit
shows before you you could
you didn't have to buy a used car
yeah it was
but today wow
The Avenues are it's huge I mean look at
all the the outlets
wow yeah for a kid today God bless them
you know wow good luck and I'm
hats off to them you know uh so he was
told uh he's still the best
huh you were told you're still the best
and voices
thank you
thank you so one of the things you
touched on it a little bit though with
the animated movie getting uh knocked
off on page 17
um but a lot of people or I think the
producers did not realize how popular
Optimus was and what the character meant
to so many people because when I was
researching prepping to talk to you I
read how many kids were leaving the
theater crying and so I'm just curious
when did you realize was it that movie
that you realized oh wait this character
is very popular I didn't know there was
no thermometer back in those days
you know there was no internet there was
nothing where people could send in their
feelings and
fan mail we never received we never got
it it never went to us personally so we
had no thermometers to judge that and
you know the first thing honestly I mean
I said who the hell did I
uh politely annoy you know who did I
know they do
[Music]
you look at yourself and then you say
forget it you know go on to the next
audition you know
and you get it behind you but that's you
know
all right I'll just move on to something
else oh yeah yeah I'll just leave I'll
just move on so one of the things about
about rise of the beasts which is what
everyone just saw is that Stephen cable
your director was a fan since he was a
kid and I would imagine that brought
that excitement must have come in when
he was recording with you and directing
you in the booth so talk a little bit
about working with someone who's a huge
fan who's now the director what a
pleasure I mean what a pleasure I guess
it's the first time in my life where I
ever worked with a director
that um that knew who I was you know and
and appreciated me for it so I mean it
was probably I I loved going to work
when they called me I couldn't wait to
get there and he's such a great guy and
so talented
I just uh
I enjoy him immensely yeah I I'm sure
he's going to have an incredible career
yeah he's going to land on his feet he's
gonna he's gonna be okay
[Laughter]
um
I definitely want to know you just saw
the movie the other night is it still a
thrill for you what is your feeling when
you're going into a theater to watch
Optimus for the first time in a new
movie
knowing everyone thinks of you as the
character because you are the character
what is it like watching it
very self-conscious uh I am I'm
self-conscious here too because
I can't really see you guys out there
that likes her so bright
and
it's like somebody just gave me the
finger I swear to go
oh I see five oh
that was close so
um
no I'm very aware of it and uh you know
and and it's important to me you know
how can you avoid not feeling the the
power of it all you know
um let me have how many people go to a
Premiere where you're you know
isolated as perhaps one of the you know
the keep the key roles in it but
uh it's a humbling feeling
it's very humbling and uh nerve-wracking
and a Long Way From Home
you know for sure yeah um I think it's
gonna be my last question for you for
people that right
for for people that want to do what
you're doing is there any advice you
want to give them about how to do voices
what you learned or you know anything
you want to pass on to another
generation of people that are so
inspired by your work
well thanks that's a good question too
um I think you have to listen to people
that tell you you know you're really
good at something
and you should try out and uh or try to
do that or hey you know if you're an
athlete or whatever
I mean if you feel it yourself you
should get out and and stick with it do
it
because believe me you know if you work
at it
you will become successful eventually no
matter what it is it's like working a
muscle the more you work it the bigger
it gets
and uh if you do something you love
that's what I tell kids
if you find something you love to do
it
stick with it
and you'll never work a day in your life
you love it it's just a holiday
uh on that note ladies and gentlemen I
would like to say a huge thank you to
Peter Cullen for joining us this evening
after our screening
foreign